first we want to thank google a
unforgetable experience
let's say that none of us
we knew and when we got to a place that did not
you knew anyone and go out with four
people that are your team and that
really organize with that together you
insists a team has been a
very very good experience the part
of the mentors the experience of being
in the google offices here in bogota
to know all the let's say that all the
technological entrepreneurship ecosystem
waths up
hello, I'm felipe, sofa, I'm a developer
google senior program work here in
san francisco with the google cloud is
with the favorite product is my cave here
and today comes to present to the
Winners of the Persians
the sets I was doing on how
work with open data how to analyze
public data and it was super interesting
sit with them talk about these
topics for a super enriching encounter
talk to
my Latin American colleagues and know
what's happening how can improve the
situation in our different countries
open data is a super topic
important that was ahead
we
you
debugging
hello everyone i'm Andrea from the match group
point of colombia in this we are
programming google glass for the first time
time
let's see how the idea works is that
then the times to the top
and you talk to him then ok google and hard to
chat then ok glass
and it gives you options then you can record
a video about photography send a
message call someone we are going to take
a Czech picture picture
our channel our cameraman is
online
hello we are a little better anecdotes
argentina we understand clearly the ntv channel
then we tell our
family that when leaving on TV
I brought a dress to leave all
prepared and when we arrived put
there was a fire truck that was going to
look at efe-tv and I had the face
they are forgiven they are
forgiven because the mdb mountain view
it's amazing the amazing place of the
incredible google stations all the
complex that have the development
technological pizza head is
awesome fast and you're already walking
very good looking everything very well
latina
plants
the purification record
yes
hi how about my name is mario valle
I work in electronics
of business development for markets
emerging with a special focus on the
Latin America I'm here on the google
of belo but you are very happy is for
here and very grateful for the invitation
I was chatting with several of you
and several of the entrepreneurs of the
Belo for two and very happy to see the
really interesting projects I think
which is a really successful initiative
which google is concentrating on
emerging markets like latin america
to identify developers
talented super projects
interesting and I also think that in
general approach and approach
who are doing these from belo pérez to
silicon valley is being very
helpful from the point of view that
they come with an energy and with a
perspective of seizing every moment and
every conversation that you notice in the
faces and it shows in every moment
in which one is talking to them
they knew their products talking about the
different features and the different
characteristic
your products so congratulations was
really a very experience
interesting to have been here with
your
as a mentor he also tried what I have
for some years now, advising
startups I have a great taste in my mouth
to identify that there is still a
mass and a very mass creation
interesting in terms of
developers in latin america in
all Latin American countries well
I'm sure we'll be
watching and I will not take your eyes off
to google to see evidence in the next
health months
yes